The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: In the last two
lectures, we saw how periodic
and non periodic signals could
be represented as linear
combinations of complex
exponentials.
And this led to the Fourier
series representation, in the
periodic case, and it led
to the Fourier transform
representation in the
aperiodic case.
And then, in fact, what we did
was to incorporate the Fourier
series within the framework
of the Fourier transform.
What I'd like to do in today's
lecture is look at the Fourier
transform more closely, in
particular with regard to some
of its properties.
So let me begin by reminding
you of the analysis and
synthesis equations for the
Fourier transform, as I've
summarized them here.
The synthesis equation being an
equation the tells us how
to build the time function out
of, in essence, a linear
combination of complex
exponentials.
And the analysis equation
telling us how to get the
amplitudes of those complex
exponentials from the
associated time function.
So essentially, in the
decomposition of x of t as a
linear combination of complex
exponentials, the complex
amplitudes of those are, in
effect, the Fourier transform
scaled by the differential and
scaled by 1 over 2 pi.
As I indicated last time, the
Fourier transform is a complex
function of frequency.
And in particular, the complex
function of frequency has an
important and very useful
symmetry property.
The symmetry of the Fourier
transform, when x of t is
real, is what is referred to
as conjugate symmetric.
In other words, if we take the
complex function, f of omega,
and its complex conjugate,
that's equivalent to replacing
omega by minus omega.
And a consequence of that, if we
think in terms of the real
part of the Fourier transform,
the real part is an even
function of frequency, and the
magnitude is an even function
of frequency.
Whereas the imaginary part is an
odd function of frequency,
and the phase angle is an odd
function of frequency.
So we have this symmetry
relationship that, for x of t
real, if we think of either the
real part or the magnitude
of the Fourier transform,
it's even symmetric.
And the imaginary part, or the
phase angle, either one, is
odd symmetric.
In other words, if we flip it,
we multiply by a minus sign.
Let's look at an example, in the
context of an example that
we worked last time for
the Fourier transform.
We took the case of a real
exponential of the form e to
the minus at times the step.
And the Fourier transform, as we
found, was of the algebraic
form 1 over a plus j omega.
And, incidentally, the Fourier
transform integral only
converged for a greater
than 0.
In other words, for this
exponential decaying.
And I illustrated the magnitude
and angle, and what
we see is that e to the minus
at is a real time function,
therefore its magnitude should
be an even function of
frequency, and indeed it is.
And its phase angle,
shown below, is an
odd function of frequency.
So in fact, although I stressed
last time that the
complex exponentials is required
to build a time
function require exponentials of
both positive and negative
frequencies, for x of t real
what we see is that, because
of these symmetry properties,
either for the real and
imaginary or magnitude and
angle, we can specify the
Fourier transform for, let's say
only positive frequencies,
and the symmetry, then, implies,
or tells us, what the
Fourier transform, then, would
be for the negative
frequencies.
This same example, the
decaying exponential,
demonstrates another important
and often useful property of
the Fourier transform.
Specifically, let's rewrite,
algebraically, this example as
I indicate here.
So we have, again, the
exponential, whose Fourier
transform is 1 over
a plus j omega.
And if I just simply divide
numerator and denominator by
a, I can rewrite it in
the form shown here.
And what we notice is that in
the time function we have a
term of the form a times t, and
in the frequency function
we have a term of the form
omega divided by a.
Or equivalently, we could think
of the time function,
which I show here, and as the
parameter a gets smaller, the
exponential gets spread
out in time.
Whereas its Fourier transform,
or the magnitude of its
Fourier transform, has the
inverse property that as a
gets smaller, in fact, this
scales down in frequency.
Well, this is a general property
of the Fourier
transform, namely the fact that
a linear scaling in time
generates the inverse linear
scaling in frequency.
And the general statement of
this time frequency scaling is
what I show at the top of the
transparency, namely the
equation that if we scale the
time function in time, then we
apply an inverse scaling
in frequency.
This, in fact, is probably a
result that you're already
possibly familiar with,
in somewhat
of a different context.
Essentially, you could think
of this as an example, or a
generalization, rather, of the
notion that if, let's say I
had a signal that was recorded
on a tape player, and if I
play the tape back at, let's
say, twice the speed, which
means that I'm compressing
the time axis linearly
by a factor of 2.
Then, in fact, what happens is
that the frequencies that we
observe get pushed up
by a factor of 2.
And, in fact, let me
illustrate that.
I have here a glockenspiel, and
anyone who loves a parade
certainly knows what
a glockenspiel is.
And this particular glockenspiel
has three a's,
separated each by an octave.
There's a middle a, a
high a, and a low a.
And what I've done is to record
the middle a on a tape
at 7 and 1/2 inches
per second.
And what I'd like to demonstrate
is that as we play
that back, either at twice or
half speed, the effective note
gets moved down or
up by an octave.
So let me first play the
note at the speed at
which it was recorded.
And so what we'll hear is the
middle a as I've recorded it.
And let me just start
the tape player.
Let me stop it, and hopefully
what you heard is the same
note from the tape recorder as
the note that I played on the
glockenspiel.
Now I'll rewind the tape, and
we'll go back to the beginning
of that portion.
And now, if I change the tape
speed to half the speed, so
from 7 and 1/2 inches per
second, I'll change the tape
speed to 3 and 3/4 inches
per second.
And now when I play the tape
back, because of the inverse
relationship between time and
frequency scaling, we're now
scaling in time by stretching
out, we would expect the
frequencies to be lowered
by a factor of 2.
We should now expect the taped
note to be an octave lower,
matching this lower a.
So let's just play that.
Let me stop it, and, again,
we'll rewind the tape.
Go back to the beginning,
and now we'll play this
at twice the speed.
So I'll change from 3 and 3/4
to 15 inches per second.
And now when I play it, we would
expect that to match the
upper note.
And let's just do that.
Although that's a result that,
intuitively, probably makes
considerable sense, in fact,
what that is is an
illustration of the inverse
relationship between time
scaling and frequency scaling.
And also, by the way, it was
finally my opportunity to play
the glockenspiel
on television.
In addition, there is another
very important relationship
between the time and frequency
domains, namely what is
referred to as a duality
relationship.
And the duality relationship
between time and frequency
falls out, more or less
directly, from the equations,
the analysis and synthesis
equations.
In particular, if we look at the
synthesis equation, which
I repeat here, and the analysis
equation, which I
repeat below it, what we observe
is that, in fact,
these equations are basically
identical, except for the fact
that in the top integral we have
things as a function of
omega, in the bottom integral
as a function of t, and
there's a factor of 1 over
2 pi, and, by the
way, a minus sign.
You can look at the algebra
more carefully at your
leisure, but essentially what
this says is that if x of
omega is the Fourier transform
of a time function x of t,
then, in fact, x of t is very
much like the Fourier
transform of x of omega.
In fact, it's the Fourier
transform of x of minus omega
to account for this
minus sign.
And, by the way, there's
just an additional
factor of 1 over 2 pi.
So the duality relationship
which follows from these two
equations, in fact, says that if
x of t and x of omega are a
Fourier transform pair, if x and
X are a Fourier transform
pair, then X, in fact, has a
Fourier transform which is
proportional to x
turned around.
This duality in the continuous
time Fourier
transform is very important.
It's very useful.
It, by the way, is not a duality
that surfaced in the
Fourier series, because, as you
recall, the Fourier series
begins with a continuous time
function and in the frequency
domain generates a sequence,
which would just naturally
have problems associated with
it if we attempted to
interpret a duality.
And we'll see, also, that in the
discrete time case, one of
the important differences
between continuous time and
discrete time Fourier transforms
is the fact that in
continuous time we have duality,
in the discrete time
Fourier transform we don't.
Let's illustrate this
with an example.
Here are, in fact, two examples
of Fourier transform
pairs taken from examples
in the text.
The top one being example 4.11
from the text, and it's a time
function which is a sine x
over x type of function.
And its Fourier transform
corresponds to a rectangular
shape in the frequency domain.
There's also another example in
the text, the example that
precedes this one, which
is example 4.10.
And in example 4.10, we begin
with a rectangle, and its
Fourier transform is
of the form of a
sine x over x function.
So in fact, if we look at these
two examples together,
what we see is the duality
very evident.
In other words, if we take this
time function and instead
think of a frequency function
that has the same form, then
we simply interchange the roles
of time and frequency in
the other domains.
So the fact that these two
correspond means that these
two correspond.
Of course in this particular
example, because of the fact
that we picked a symmetric
function, an even function, in
fact, the additional twist of
the time axis being reversed
didn't show up in duality
with this example.
One thing this says, of course,
is that essentially
any time you've calculated the
Fourier transform of one time
function, then you've actually
calculated the Fourier
transform of two
time functions.
Another one being the dual
example to the one that you
just calculated.
Also somewhat related to duality
is what is referred to
as Parseval's relation
for the continuous
time Fourier transform.
And essentially, what Parseval's
relationship says,
as a summary of it, says that
the energy in a time function
and the energy in its Fourier
transform are proportional,
the proportionality factor
being a factor of 2 pi.
That's summarized here.
What's meant by the energy is,
of course, the integral of the
magnitude squared of x of t.
And the statement of Parseval's
relation is that
that integral, the energy in x
of t, is proportional to this
integral, which is the
energy in x of omega.
Although we've incorporated the
Fourier series within a
framework of the Fourier
transform, Parseval's relation
needs to be modified slightly
for Fourier series, because of
the fact that a periodic signal
has an infinite amount
of energy in it, and,
essentially, that form of
Parseval's relationship for the
periodic case would say
infinity equals infinity,
which isn't too useful.
However, it can be modified so
that Parseval's relationship
to the periodic case says,
essentially, that the energy
in one period of the periodic
time function is proportional
with, this is the
proportionality factor,
proportional to the sum of the
magnitude squared of the
coefficients.
In other words, the energy in
one period is proportional to
the energy in the sequence that
represents the Fourier
series coefficients.
There are lots of other
properties, and they're
developed in the text and
in the study guide.
A number of properties that we
want to make particular use of
during this lecture, and in
later lectures, are ones that
I summarize here.
And I won't demonstrate the
proofs, but principally focus
on some of the interpretation
as the lecture goes on.
The first property that I have
listed here is what's referred
to as the time shifting
property.
And the time shifting property
says, if I have a time
function with a Fourier
transform x of omega, if I
shift that time function in
time, then that corresponds to
multiplying the Fourier
transform by this factor.
As you examine this factor, what
you can see is that this
factor has magnitude unity and
it has a phase, which is
linear with frequency, and
a slope of minus t0.
So a statement to remember, that
will come up many times
throughout the course, is
that a time shift, or a
displacement in time,
corresponds to a linear change
in phase and frequency.
Another property and, in fact,
a pair of properties that
we'll make reference to as we
turn our attention toward the
end of this lecture to solving
differential equations using
the Fourier transform, is what's
referred to as the
differentiation property and
its companion, which is the
integration property.
The differentiation property
says, again, if we have a time
function with Fourier transform
x of omega, the
Fourier transform of the time
derivative of that corresponds
to multiplying the Fourier
transform by a linear function
of frequency.
So here it's a linear amplitude
change that
corresponds to differentiation.
At first glance, what you
might think is that the
integration property is just
the reverse of that.
If for the differentiation
property you multiply by j
omega, then for integration you
must divide by j omega.
And that's almost correct,
except not quite.
And the reason for the not quite
is that recall that if
you differentiate, what happens,
of course, is that
you lose a constant.
And if we have a time function
that's some finite energy
signal plus a constant,
differentiating will destroy
the constant.
The integration property,
in essence, tries
to bring that back.
So the integration property,
which is the inverse of the
differentiation property, says
that we divide the transform
by j omega, and then if, in
fact, there was a constant
added to x of t, we have to
account for that by inserting
an impulse into the
Fourier transform.
And the final property that I
want to draw your attention to
on this view graph is the
linearity property, which is
very straightforward to
demonstrate from the analysis
and synthesis equations, which
simply says if x1 of omega is
the Fourier transform x1 of t,
and x2 of omega is the Fourier
transform of x2 of t, then the
Fourier transform of a linear
combination is a linear
combination of the Fourier
transforms.
Let me emphasize, also, that
these properties, for the most
part, apply both to Fourier
series and Fourier transforms
because, in fact, what we've
done is to incorporate the
Fourier series within
the framework
of the Fourier transform.
We'll be using a number of these
properties shortly, when
we turn our attention to linear
constant coefficient
differential equations.
However, before we do that
I'd like to focus on two
additional major properties, and
these are what I refer to
as the convolution property and
the modulation property.
And in fact, the convolution
property, as I'm about to
introduce it, forms the
mathematical and conceptual
basis for the whole notion of
filtering, which, in fact,
will be a topic by itself in a
set of lectures, and, in fact,
is a chapter by itself
in the textbook.
Similarly, what I'll refer to
as the modulation property,
again, will occupy its own set
of lectures as we go through
the course, and, in
fact, has its own
chapter in the textbook.
Let me just indicate what the
convolution property is.
And what the convolution
property tells us is that the
Fourier transform of the
convolution of two time
functions is the product of
their Fourier transforms.
So it says, for example, that
if I have a linear time
invariant system, and I have
an input x of t, an impulse
response h of t, and the output,
of course, being the
convolution, then, in fact,
if I look at this in the
frequency domain, the Fourier
transform of the output is the
Fourier transform of the input
times the Fourier transform of
the impulse response.
You can demonstrate this
property algebraically by
essentially taking the
convolution integral and
applying the Fourier transform
and doing the appropriate
interchanging of the order of
integration, et cetera.
But what I'd like to draw your
attention to is a somewhat
more intuitive interpretation
of the property.
And the intuitive interpretation
stems from the
relationship between the Fourier
transform of the
impulse response and what
we've referred to as the
frequency response.
Recall that one of the things
that led us to use complex
exponentials as building blocks
was the fact that
they're eigenfunctions
of linear
time and variant systems.
In other words, if we have a
linear time invariant system,
and I have an input which is
a complex exponential, the
output is a complex exponential
of the same
frequency multiplied
by what we call
the frequency response.
And, in fact, the expression for
the frequency response is
identical to the expression for
the Fourier transform of
the impulse response.
In other words, the frequency
response is the Fourier
transform of the impulse
response.
Now in that context, how
can we interpret
the convolution property?
Well, remember what I said at
the beginning of the lecture,
when I pointed to the synthesis
equation and I said,
in essence, the synthesis
equation tells us how to
decompose x of t as a linear
combination of complex
exponentials.
What are the complex amplitudes
of those complex
exponentials?
In terms of our notation here,
the complex amplitude of those
complex exponentials is x of
omega, or proportional to x of
omega, in particular it's x of
omega, d omega, and then a
factor of 2 pi.
As this signal goes through
this linear time invariant
system, what happens to each of
those exponential is each
one gets multiplied by the
frequency response at the
associated frequency.
What comes out is the amplitude
of the complex
exponentials that are used
to build the output.
So in fact, the convolution
property simply is telling us
that, in terms of the
decomposition of the signal,
in terms of complex
exponentials, as we push that
signal through a linear time
invariant system, we're
separately multiplying by the
frequency response, the
amplitudes of the exponential
components used
to build the input.
And that sum, in turn, is the
decomposition of the output in
terms of complex exponentials.
I understand that going through
that involves a little
bit of sorting out, and I
strongly encourage you to try
to understand and interpret the
convolution property in
those conceptual terms, rather
than simply by applying the
mathematics to the convolution
integral and seeing the terms
match up on both sides.
As I indicated, the convolution
property forms the
basis for what's referred
to as filtering.
And this is a topic that we'll
be treating in a considerable
amount of detail after we've
also gone through a discussion
of the discrete time Fourier
transform in the
next several lectures.
However, what I'd like to do
is just indicate, now, a
little bit of the conceptual
ideas involved.
Essentially, conceptually,
what filtering, as it's
typically referred to,
corresponds to is modifying
separately the individual
frequency
components in a signal.
The convolution property told
us that if we look at the
individual frequency components,
they get
multiplied by the frequency
response, and so what that
says is that we can amplify
or attenuate any of those
components separately using a
linear time invariant system.
For example, what I've
illustrated here is the
frequency response of what is
commonly referred to as an
ideal low pass filter.
What an ideal low pass filter
does is to pass exactly
frequencies in one frequency
range and eliminate totally
frequencies outside
that range.
Another filter which is not so
ideal might, for example,
attenuate components in
this band but not
totally eliminate them.
In terms of filtering, we
can think back to the
differentiation property
and, in fact, interpret
differentiator as a filter.
Recall that the differentiation
property said
that the Fourier transform of
the differentiated signal is
the Fourier transform of
the original signal
multiplied by j omega.
So what that says, then,
is that if we have a
differentiator, the frequency
response of that is j omega.
In other words, the Fourier
transform of the output is j
omega times the Fourier
transform of the input.
And so the frequency response
of the differentiator looks
like this, in terms
of its magnitude.
And what it does, of course,
is it amplifies high
frequencies and attenuates
low frequencies.
Let me just, to cement some of
these ideas, illustrate them
in the context of one kind of
signal, namely a signal which,
in fact, is a spatial signal
rather than a time signal.
And this also gives me an
opportunity to introduce you
to our colleague, J.
B. J. Fourier.
So if we could look at our
colleague, Mr. Fourier, who,
by the way, is not only a person
who had tremendously
brilliant insights, and his
insights, in fact, have led to
forming the foundation of the
developments that is the basis
for this course.
He was also a very
interesting, fascinating person.
And there's a certain amount of
historical discussion about
Fourier and his background,
which you might enjoy reading
in the text.
In any case, what you're
looking at, of
course, is a signal.
And the signal is a spatial
signal, and it has high
frequencies and low
frequencies.
High frequencies corresponding
to things that are varying
rapidly spatially, and
low frequencies
varying slowly spatially.
And so, for example, we could
low pass filter this picture
simply by asking the video crew
if they could be slightly
defocus it.
And what you see as the picture
is defocused, if you
could hold it there, is that
we've lost edges, which is the
rapid variation.
And what we've retained is the
broader, slow variation.
And now let's take out the
defocusing low pass filter and
go back to a focused image.
What we can also consider is
what would happen if we looked
at the differentiated image.
And there are several ways
we can think about this.
One is that a differentiator--
Of course the output of a
differentiator is larger where
the discontinuity, or where
the variation, is faster.
And so we would expect the edges
to be enhanced if, in
fact, we differentiated
the image.
Or if we interpret
differentiation in the context
of our filter, then what we're
saying is that, in effect,
what's happening is that the
differentiator is accentuating
the high frequencies because of
the frequency shape of the
differentiator.
Recall that this all fits
together as a nice package.
We expect intuitively
that differentiation
will enhance edges.
When we talked about square
waves and we saw how the
Fourier series built up a square
wave, we saw that it
was the high frequencies that
were required in order to
build up the sharp edges.
And so either viewed as a
filter, or viewed intuitively,
we would expect that the
differentiated image would, in
fact, attenuate this slowly
varying background and amplify
the rapidly varying edges.
So let's look again at our
original image, just to remind
you of the fact that there are
edges, of course, and there is
a more slowly varying
background.
And now let's look at the result
of passing that through
a differentiator.
And, as I think is very evident
in the resulting
image, clearly it's the edges
that are retained and the
slower background variations
are destroyed, which is
consistent with everything
that we've said.
I've emphasized that we'll be
returning to a much broader
discussion of filtering at a
later point in the course.
I'd now like to comment on
another property, which is
also, as I indicated, a topic
in its own right, and which
really is the dual property to
the convolution property, and,
in fact, could be argued
directly from duality.
And that is what's referred to
as the modulation property.
The convolution property told us
that if we convolve in the
time domain, we multiply in
the frequency domain.
And we know that time and
frequency domains are
interchangeable because of
duality, so what that would
suggest is that if we multiply
in the time domain, that would
correspond to convolution
in the frequency domain.
And, in fact, that is
exactly what the
modulation property is.
I have it summarized here that
if we multiply a time function
by another time function,
then in the
frequency domain we convolve.
Whereas the convolution property
is just the dual of
that, namely convolving in the
time domain corresponds to
multiplication in the
frequency domain.
The convolution property
is the basis, as I
indicated, for filtering.
The modulation property, as I've
summarized it here, in
fact, is the entire basis for
amplitude modulation systems
as used almost universally
in communications.
And what the modulation
property, as we'll see when we
explore it in more detail, tells
us is that if we have a
signal with a certain spectrum,
and we multiply by a
sinusoidal signal whose Fourier
transform is a set of
impulses, then in a frequency
domain we convolve.
And that corresponds to taking
the original spectrum and
translating it, shifting it in
frequency up to the frequency
of the carrier, namely the
sinusoidal signal.
And as I said, we'll come to
that in much more detail in a
number of lectures.
We've seen a number of
properties, and I indicated
sometime earlier when we talked
about differential
equations, that, in fact, it's
the properties of the Fourier
transform that provide us with
a very useful and important
mechanism for solving linear
constant coefficient
differential equations.
And what I'd like to do now is
illustrate the procedure, the
basis for that, and I think what
we'll do is illustrate it
simply in the context
of several examples.
What I've indicated is a
system with an impulse
response h of t, or frequency
response h of omega.
And, of course, we know that
in the time domain it's
described through convolution,
in the frequency domain it's
described through
multiplication.
And I, in essence, am assuming
that we're talking about a
linear time invariant system.
And we're also going to assume
then it's characterized by a
linear constant coefficient
differential equation, where
we're going to impose the
condition that it's causal
linear and time invariant, or
equivalently that the initial
conditions are consistent
with the initial rest.
And it's because of the fact
that we're assuming that it's
a linear time invariant system
that we can describe it in the
frequency domain through the
convolution property, and we
can use the properties of
the Fourier transform.
So let's take, as our example,
a first order differential
equation as I indicate here.
So the derivative of the output
plus a times the output
is equal to the input.
And now we can use the
differentiation property.
If we Fourier transform this
entire expression, the
differentiation property tells
us that the Fourier transform
of the derivative of the
output is the Fourier
transform of the output
multiplied by j omega.
And linearity will let us write
the Fourier transform of
this as a times y of omega.
And since these are added
together, and since we have
the linearity property, these
are added together.
And x of omega is the Fourier
transform of x of t.
So what we've used is the
differentiation property, and
we've used the linearity
property.
We can solve this equation
for y of omega.
The Fourier transform of the
output in terms of x of omega,
the Fourier transform of the
input, and a simple algebraic
step gets us to this
expression.
So the Fourier transform of the
output is 1 over j omega
plus a times the Fourier
transform of the input.
And I've just simply repeated
that equation up here.
So far this is algebra, and the
question is, now, how do
we interpret this?
Well, we know that the Fourier
transform of the output is the
Fourier transform of the input
times the Fourier transform of
the impulse response of
the system, namely
the frequency response.
So, in fact, if we think of
h of t and h of omega as a
Fourier transform pair, it's the
convolution property that
lets us equate this term
with h of omega.
So here we're using the
convolution property.
So we know what the Fourier
transform of the impulse
response is, namely 1
over j omega plus a.
We may have, for example, wanted
in our problem, instead
of getting the frequency
response, to
get the impulse response.
And there are a variety of
ways that we can do this.
We can attempt to go through the
inverse Fourier transform
expression.
But in fact, one of the most
useful ways is formally called
the inspection method.
Informally it's called, if you
worked it out going one way,
then you ought to remember the
answer so that you know how to
get back method.
So what that says is, remember
that we worked an example, and
in fact I showed you the
example earlier in the
lecture, that the Fourier
transform of e to the minus at
times the step is 1 over
j omega plus a?
So what is the inverse Fourier
transfer of 1 over
j omega plus a?
Well, it's e to the minus
at times a unit step.
And that's just simply
remembering, in essence, this
particular transform pair.
I've drawn, graphically, the
magnitude of the Fourier
transform here.
And below it we have the
impulse response.
The impulse response is, as I
just indicated, e to the minus
at times u of t.
Now let's go back up and look
at the magnitude of the
frequency response.
And given just the little bit
of discussion that we had
previously about filtering, you
should be able to infer
something about the filtering
characteristics of this
simple, first order differential
equation.
In particular, if you look at
that frequency response, the
frequency response falls off
with frequency and so what it
tends to do is attenuate high
frequencies and retain low
frequencies.
So in fact, you could think of
the defocusing that we did on
the image of Fourier, you
could think of that,
approximately, as similar to the
kind of filtering action
that you would get by passing a
signal through a first order
differential equation.
Just to illustrate one
additional step in both
evaluating inverse transforms
and using Fourier transform
properties to solve linear
constant coefficient
differential equations, let's
take the same example and,
rather than finding the impulse
response, let's find
the response to another
exponential input.
We could, of course,
do that using
the convolution integral.
We've just gotten the impulse
response, and we could put
that through the convolution
integral to get the response
to this input.
But let's do it, instead,
by going back to the
differential equation.
And so here I'm taking a
I'll choose, just to have
some numbers to work
with, a equal to 2.
And now I'll choose an
exponential on the right hand
side, e to the minus
t times u of t.
And again, we Fourier transform
the equation.
And we can remember
this particular
Fourier transform pair.
It's just the one we worked
out previously, now with a
equal to 1.
Clearly we're getting a lot of
mileage out of that example.
And now, if we want to determine
what the output y of
t is, we can do that by solving
for y of omega and
then generating the inverse
Fourier transform.
Let's solve this algebraically
for y of omega, and that gets
us to this expression.
And this is not a Fourier
transform that we've worked
out before.
And this is the second part to
the inspection procedure.
What we have is a Fourier
transform which is a product
of two terms, each of which
we can recognize.
And what we can consider doing
is expanding that out in a
partial fraction expansion,
namely as a sum of terms.
Because of the linearity
property associated with the
Fourier transform, the inverse
transform is then the sum of
the inverse transform of
each of those terms.
So if we expand this out in a
partial fraction expansion,
and you can just verify that if
you add these two together
you'll get back to
where we started.
We now have the sum of two
terms, and if we now
recognize, by inspection, the
inverse Fourier transform of
this, we see that it's simply
minus e to the minus 2t times
the unit step.
This one is plus e to the minus
t times the unit step.
And so, in fact, it's the sum
of these two terms which are
the inverse transforms of the
individual terms in the
partial fraction expansion that
then give us the output.
So this is y of t, which
is the sum of these two
exponentials, and this is the
inverse Fourier transform of y
of omega as we calculated
it previously.
Hopefully you're beginning to
get some sense, now, of how
powerful and also beautiful
the Fourier transform is.
We've seen already a glimpse
of how it plays a role in
filtering, modulation, how its
properties help us with linear
constant coefficient
differential
equations, et cetera.
What we will do, beginning
with the next lecture, is
develop a similar set of tools
for the discrete time case.
And there are some very strong
similarities to what we've
done in continuous time, also
some very important
differences.
And then, after we have the
continuous time and discrete
time Fourier transforms, we'll
then see how the concepts
involved and the properties
involved lead to very
important and powerful notions
of filtering, modulation,
sampling, and other signal
processing ideas.
Thank you.